We’re always told to avoid eating yellow
snow… ugh.
But new research shows maybe you shouldn’t
eat any snow!
This month the entire East Coast of the US
got pummeled by a blizzard.
Businesses and schools closed leaving everyone
to cozy up by fire or go outside to do what
we love doing most.
Eating snow.
Don’t act like you’ve never done it before.
Just, some scientists recommend against it.
You’re basically eating dust and soot trapped
in water.
Yes, every snowflake already contains some
kind of dust particle because that’s how
they form.
These particles are the “seeds” on which
frozen water crystallizes to make snowflakes.
But, now research shows snowflakes can also
attract even more particles, many of which
are harmful.
And to be fair, this is the same stuff you
breath in the air too.
There’s lots of dust and pollen floating
around the air right now, and it’s mostly
fine to breathe.
But snow might just concentrate it more.
According to a study published in the journal
Environmental Science: Processes & Impacts,
snow can act kind of like a sponge.
Snowflakes, while small have a lot of surface
area, so there’s a lot of places for little
particles to stick to.
So the fumes and particles from car exhaust
get stuck in all the nooks and crannies of
a snowflake.
Unfortunately, these particles are nasty stuff,
it’s toxic and carcinogenic, which means
it can cause cancer.
These researchers put both snow and exhaust
fumes into a chamber to see what would happen.
After just an hour, the concentration of particles
in the snow dramatically increased.
The snow just soaked up the exhaust from the
air around it.
So how much of this pollution is in snow?
Well according to one study published in Science,
in some cities in the Great Plains, concentrations
could be as high as 7 micrograms of soot per
cubic meter of snow.
Which is still less than the National Ambient
Air Quality Standards maximum of 35 mg per
cubic meter.
So it’s well below toxic levels.
Now if you want to be on the safe side, maybe
avoid the first snowfall of the day.
The snow acts like a filter as it falls, it
captures all that dust and pollution in the
air.
But after the first few hours, there’s less
pollution in the air.
So less pollution to get caught in the snow.
But some still recommend caution, one lead
researcher suggests avoiding eating snow in
big cities.
Dr. Parisa Ariya, told the Huffington Post
that, “As a mother who is an atmospheric
physical chemist, she definitely does not
suggest her young kids to eat snow in urban
areas in general."
Yet other scientists, like Staci Simonich
from Oregon State University told NPR that
she “would not hesitate for her children
to have the joy of eating a handful of fresh
fallen snow from my backyard”.
If you’re worried about snow you should
avoid, stick to the white stuff.
Other colors signal contaminants.
Brown snow means it’s well… obviously
dirty.
It’s when more dust and dirt sticks to the
snow.
Pink snow, sometimes called watermelon snow,
while pretty actually means it’s filled
with algae, a photosynthetic microbe you definitely
don’t want to eat.
There’s so much to know about snow!
Trace explains 13 things you probably didn’t
know about snow in this episode right here.